so I got this question how do you
prevent your skin from sagging as you
lose weight
I've had people not want to lose weight
because they thought their skin is going
to Sag think about this your skin is an
organ it's one of the largest organs in
the body and as you get healthy that
skin heals that collagen heals up so the
only way you're going to get sagging
skin when you lose weight is if you lose
weight unhealthy like a gastric bypass
or a major starvation diet like HCG or
something like that which you're doing
500 calories so as long as you're losing
weight healthily the skin will adapt to
the weight loss because we almost want
to have you lose weight kind of
gradually over time but have the skin
come in there and get toned that way and
if you have sagging belly I created a
video on my blog where you can do
sit-ups in Reverse so most people do
sit-ups where they're coming this way
which basically just contracts and makes
the skin looser but you want to do
reverse ups you're going to go back and
stretch backwards and tighten the skin
so in other words do the program
healthily and the skin will not be
sagging and it'll be more gradual and if
you had stretch marks I have a video on
how to get rid of that on my blog so
check it out but that's pretty much the
answer to that one